what's happening in ukraine a democracy
attacked by its nuclear-powered neighbor
is giving lots of people pause for
thought about what they would do how far
they would go to defend their
independence and resist the russians
despite the seemingly impossible odds
many ukrainians are unwilling to step
aside
as the sounds of war overrun ukraine and
people run for cover
in a country where men are being told to
fight
these sounds are hard to bear
here a man can hardly break away from
his daughter and his partner
for those who remain there are deep
signs of defiance
people who are unwilling to yield
this woman confronted heavily armed
russian soldiers you are occupiers and
fascists she says take these seeds and
put them in your pockets at least she
says sunflowers will grow when you die
here
the sunflower is ukraine's national
flower
and on this rocky island in the black
sea the same will to resist
a russian warship blared an ultimatum at
a small team of ukrainian border guards
lay down your arms and surrender they
said otherwise you'll be bombed
their response
russian warship
go f yourself
the ship opened fire
ukraine says 13 border guards were
killed
across the country people are choosing
to fight rather than flee
this apartment block in keeve took a
direct hit
inside oksana golenko was thrown across
her bedroom oh yes paula i was
completely confused she says i heard
screams sounds i got up and saw all the
windows smashed
she and her daughter are now picking up
the pieces
and under her breath
she's singing ukraine's national anthem
long live ukraine she says